full podcast welcome to the worth of
food podcast episode 2 of 2020 or a
purse or even know why pursue these days
well fewer choices here Marcin drizzle
here Lisa here Paula shows here the
ledger world-famous here think highly
sure man my card man yeah I said daisy
fuentes apologize to make that I just
make that up for I was young right now
brother last two minutes I finally
really oh you made something up I had to
make it up bro you made up a story just
to you know give us a Hollywood Reporter
right later not a lot of news going
around with a comedian man about bro
Williams ya hear the story that he was
on a Doug Benson's podcast with Eddie
IFFT and he did a story about him on the
road ghosts raping somebody or what's it
called
I mean you switch fraud by rape rape by
fraud we do the switch aroma he'll use a
little guy yeah it was on um on that
show getting done with Hyde and after
the Oneiros stories
Eddie IFFT and Doug Benson I tell ya one
time call them and see at night we're
having it's getting good now yeah we're
having Carlos you like oh [ __ ] this
little [ __ ] wanted some [ __ ] and I
made up my man that's all that happened
they go thought she was in she was doing
it with Mencia she blew the bus driver
by the way to the story so another guy
other story it's wild to wild store how
many [ __ ] so I guess Brad Williams
hopped in and took his place and then
the girl didn't know and select 15
minutes later so yeah so that's what
happened so then to slow
[Music]
he was having to sleep with Carlos it's
technically rape and then and went viral
but he was attacked by everybody like
you rapist here's the question did when
the girl found out she was [ __ ] the
little dude no she never found she was
very drunk
supposedly yeah but did she care when
she found out with a little D as well
yeah she did care she got mad yeah yeah
man merge back
know that that he was the oil yeah he
the story was that he pushed him in
there yeah he pushed he was wearing him
like like like dr. evil mini-me like
enough he was bred way that was in a
wearing him like columnist you know
wearing brown like a fanny pack and when
I always hear like stories about Carlos
kind of [ __ ] on his openers and like
dissing people like that was pretty
generous don't share tour-bus [ __ ] no
no girls don't want to have sex with the
openers these guys he opens yeah yeah
right let's read so you guys open for it
both you guys open for him yeah yeah
yeah so well he's not gonna be doing
anything like that cuz he's married so
are you guys gonna maybe do it to it
marry to
where the babe you got the girl bro I
got ever happened Oprah William later on
said today said that never happened 9-11
p.m. the play that story up because he
was a young comic four years ago mmm
okay so who did that maybe it didn't I
don't know I'm sure it never happened as
Carlos do he'll tell you man I don't
have a number call his opener commerce
commerce guy said no but that's happened
before were the girls had the girls give
the bus driver oral sex to get on the
bus and the bus drivers like if you
ain't [ __ ] the band if you ain't
suckin the band get the [ __ ] off the bus
so where'd you go home three chicks left
rodrigo stay she's gonna be a Kansas
City mister baby like make a Chinese
soldier that was cool yeah being Casey
this weekend at the improv in uh yeah
Casey Abby we good it's a good room you
know so she went up to man I don't know
dude now do you throw the comedy bro
natural yeah that's true yeah yeah yeah
I just that size the better room yeah no
I don't know I've been there since I've
been four you know the store since I've
been four it's weird to change it so
much I went on last night
and everyone in the audience is so PC
it's hilarious hilarious right yeah for
the ass joke man
he always tells me when I'm stoned and I
[ __ ] only laugh the one about the one
if I raised or bro that joke if I'm
gonna give me a doctor but it's
hilarious you know like everyone in the
audience and the o.r last night seemed
like they came there on on birds it's
more challenging you know it's more
chance cuz at the store it's like you
know people don't go there to see the
convenience they go there to see all the
give me experience yeah yeah the
experience so it's like for me you know
I have a certain audience that that I
work to on the road and I know I can be
real comfortable just like they come to
see you you can do anything and they
just flow with you but at the store you
have to kind of and it's always been
that way it's not just recently it's
always been that way you kind of kind of
have to kind of maneuver through the
feeling of the crowd you know cuz a lot
of jokes they all have different tastes
and we're different they're not there
for you yeah they're for and just to see
and some people don't even [ __ ] know
you and you're like got a [ __ ]
maneuver you know cuz you go out on the
[ __ ] stage a pro son-in-law boom they
got it you mean or they you do jokes you
know for your audience and they and they
they're into it it's a lot easier it's
funny you know I know you got an ego in
the middle but I wear this [ __ ] know
what they go in who is this guy was he
talking about this yes sometimes they
don't you know see but you have to know
that before going into it you know and I
always like you know with my mom and
stuff at the store and always kind of
you know watching the different
comedians it's always important that I
think you know the audience it's just
like a movie you know what I mean you
know you go to watch a movie a lot of
people don't the [ __ ] going on so it's
like a comic goes onstage you have to
really kind of understand like that they
don't know the [ __ ] you are and really
kind of like that's why Roseanne Barr
when she hit with those six minutes at
the top one on the Carson show she was
so good because you really understood
who she was and I think that's important
I think it's important for comedians
to leave the stage obviously to get
laughs but more importantly who the [ __ ]
is that person and that's the
challenging part because anyone can go
up and tell jokes but you want the
executives to write a sitcom like
Seinfeld or Roseanne or you even dice
when he was doing movies or me when I
was in my movies you understood who that
person was and I think that's lost a lot
you know in in stand-ups you know it's
like who are you from where you from
it's kind of simple stuff but uh yeah
because people have their section all
over the place and there are social
media they have a point of view buddy I
think they feel like they know them or
they can go find out but you're right
people don't yeah point of view buddy
so yeah it's um you know it's always you
know I've been doing it probably what
over thirty years now so there I'm like
the older guy now which is [ __ ] weird
because always been the younger one so
it's the old Chinese guy yeah so it's
like you know you're on stage and I'm
still trying to figure it out you know
I'm still trying to figure it out I'm
really bad at jokes I'm good at setups
jokes tags are hard yeah so sometimes
that to bring in tag writers towards the
end it's like yo I've taken this [ __ ] as
far as I've taken it and tweak it you
only I mean it's like if you watch all
the talk shows at night you see these
guys like you know Jimmy Fallon and and
all these guys have tag writers these
are all joke writers yeah you know and
you need that you know sometimes you
can't just go like this I can you can
trick them for so long but then you need
joke joke joke joke
and that's hard job you still write
jokes of course every day you go over
your sets always yeah
I'm sure that [ __ ] get up the stage
like I will tell my wife go over my set
yeah and hear it again and hear the
crowd reaction and see like it's so hard
you never stop figuring it out you just
never stop trying to trying to figure it
out you know so it's it's good and I
love it you know I love it I still love
it you know I still love it you know
still like really enjoy and I think
stand-up comedy's saved my life I don't
know not from you man like watching you
like I will go to clubs and then people
will complain about what you do what
your openers doing then I think [ __ ]
that I'm doing the same [ __ ] too I will
turn the owner with what happened he was
all he had on but it wasn't so strange
and caught in the crowd you know firstly
I just listened to him but then everyone
realized one time when I was that I
wanted a club but it was there Fort
Myers and it's already adding tables in
Church of the shoulders or sold out then
I said then I'm gonna get a bonus but
they but you had a tables and chairs we
had no tables and chairs
oh you saw ok never like well we need a
[ __ ] picker now yeah we gotta be you
gotta bring the clicker you know but
again if you've been doing it as long as
I've been doing it you've been doing it
for a long time too you start to create
excuse me am the trust in a relationship
with the owners and the management that
you know what if you want to [ __ ] rob
me off of 10 tables [ __ ] do it
you don't even mean after a while but
sometimes when you play the smaller
towns yeah like I play a lot of places
that no one's ever played which is
hilarious because a lot of promoters
they find me and they're like Pauly
Shore because I'm very appeal in the
middle of a country and these [ __ ]
weird weird [ __ ] you know these weird
towns and I always say like his a comic
ever played here and they're like no I'm
like that's hilarious because I'm always
the first you don't I mean and I say
that onstage I'm like hey you know it's
like the Mikey commercial don't wanted
to do it and they got Pauly he'll do it
but I say I say this thing in my act I'm
just happy that the the currency and
like Mississippi is the same it is amali
wood because think about if you go to
Europe you know you go overseas like
sometimes like you know England is
different than France France is
differently you know imagine it's like
Texas the currency was different than
California and then you make money in in
Texas and you come and try to buy up
smoothy and West Hollywood and it's like
the money is off ya gotta be poor dude
the currency was [ __ ] you know if the
currency was different
yeah yeah cuz I do well imagine country
do taxidermy we get back
yeah so it's like he does well in the
middle of the country you do well in all
the other parts of Italy outskirts the
borders so you do do you do like but
yeah I mean he's pretty worried now yeah
little wiseguys we did that video of our
bomb party sure they're gonna be there a
month after me don't forget to create
some Chinese soup yeah you do well I
love that room that's great keith is
great up there dubs and he's a comic so
he knows how yeah for people but I think
when you do it as long as we've been
doing it people are pretty cool you know
it's like repeat business and you know
so you know why do you keep looking over
there the food coffee amazing he made
you make the cake all your pollo short
Paolo Paolo and Wow you know one of my
Guardians one of my Guardians weren't
growing up I had several Guardians
because my mom was always at the club my
parents were divorced so different
comedians party was to power Regas
watched me for sure and Paul role yeah
[Music]
yeah Paul was a
Paul's great of also there was obviously
for Freddie Prinze Freddie Prinze was
there you know back then but he didn't
babysit me but he was freed asparagus
Freddie asparagus very I was very close
to Freddie asparagus he was a sweetheart
yeah and then also Soto is where Sol de
Soto yeah he was he was a shame what
happened to him he was such a good guy
and he was so [ __ ] funny a really
nice guy he used to drive my mom's limo
you know he would drive my mom around
but um I'm sad that you never got to
meet my mom I did show good for her oh
yeah yeah in 98 that was in a row I'm
afraid of sort of passed away would you
go say hello to her in the car cause
hitting it out yeah yeah so how long you
been doing it for Tulane 1996 maybe even
doing it oh yes sir she was around yeah
yeah so uh I was there when out we had a
we had a Christmas party and I remember
the first one bear with me you him and
some other people
ten of us and nobody knew nobody wanted
to come and mean you went outside you
told me hey buddy
go get some people to come and eat and I
went to go get some comments that were
hanging outside come and eat and this
year they ran out of food because people
showed up out of nowhere that was good
of your mama was doing that man like
yeah chuja put out food for people well
she always you know the thing is with my
mom she wasn't like a lot of club owners
where she wants to manage them she was
like hey here's the stage take it and
take off you know I mean it's like
develop your stuff here and move on you
know the strike was kind of weird though
when my the convenience striked against
my mom because every night y-yes 79 or
something like that but it was weird
because what happened was is the comic
store started doing really well
financially and the comedian's wanted to
get paid and my mom didn't want to pay
the comedians because in my mom's eyes
it was our artists colony and she knew
that they would develop and then
eventually they would go make millions
of dollars so it was like a weird you
know thing and then they settled you
know eventually and they started getting
paid something but uh yeah I was you
know different comedian straight to
heaven yeah I was yeah yeah I know I was
just like I would uh cuz it was a heavy
time you know the guy jumped off the
roof yes yes Stephen Bacon jumped off
the roof
he had a suicide note that said my name
is Steve libecki and I used to be a
comedian at the Comedy Store [ __ ]
heavy dude yeah that's when there's coke
and [ __ ] all that you know now it's
like it's so like yeah yeah at the end
of that book which I requested dying up
here I'm dying of it Richard Lewis said
that I'm this began my my 25 years of
hardcore drinking yeah so um but it was
it wasn't just comedy it was just the
70s itself it was rad what year were you
born 68 okay so we're the same age yeah
oh wow okay yeah so you remember yeah
look Craig 85 yeah I wasn't afraid I was
in a breakdancing big time
well [ __ ] give me your hand
whoa dude slow relax that makes it lacks
robbery yeah
anyway I'll do it again here Ted to your
right now do it right do it right just
start it start the wave way you went too
fast slow
feel it and then you got to hit your
head and then go back beat Street baby
that's too low that [ __ ] man
make sure Boogaloo is like movie in the
army now one of the funniest movies
somebody says up there I don't know
Bobby
ham now son it's all about Sonny long in
Encino man that movie I was a kid I was
try and dig my backyard looking for
cable man
it was such a fun time movie making was
such a fun time back then not that it's
not fun now but back no they want
sequels yeah B yeah back then it was
just like before social you know what I
mean yeah cuz you you know in order to
see anything in order to see anything
you just you basically go to TV or you
go to the movie and that's it you know
mean so when you did a movie people want
to see it nothing I want to get
distracted with all these apps and this
and their Instagram and you know night
back then if you didn't see the movie
you couldn't say what more which wig
comes out here no it never came out yeah
and there's no reviews like now like
like Ron tomatoes you're like the quote
the ratings komali before or I
understand people actually knew about
Star Wars or Star Wars freaking the
early ones like the early ones did you
have the toys no I didn't have a Turk
AIDS with other little ones maybe yeah I
probably had an r2d2 or something when
you're a kid so okay so with your mom
and your dad's probably on the road all
the time
years old they took off yeah and then
so did you have like so he just asked if
you had those toys did you have any toys
did you have like a child
Mitsy like when you off at a playgroup
or daycare or we had twister we had
monopoly big trampoline my mom put a big
trampoline right in the backyard which
was awesome little Acrobat oh yeah that
was fun I should jump in the house to
the parking lot of the park common yeah
it was cool what else do we have we had
lived in the house the house up there no
that's not where you grew up right no
that makes what staying on oh that was
uh that was more of the crest Hill house
was more of a house that she bought and
then I took it over once I hit into MTV
okay and then I I took that the lease
over from her and I lived there but that
was the house that uh you know she had
it was kind of a halfway house for for
for comics and dice would lived there
and Tamayo Sookie and Yakov Smirnoff and
Karla beau was there and uh you know is
that type of thing I mean my mom was so
cool like she was like you know when she
got the comics or when she was 40 like
she just was like you know she's always
like an artist you know so she always
like she would just do [ __ ] you know I
mean she'd like make money and she goes
I'm gonna do all these [ __ ] shows and
then she just make all these shows she
was just like cool you know I'm gonna
take your mom to get the club of art
LeBeau could ever die written about that
are LeBeau just to own the building yeah
well well the comic stores three rooms
at the oh are the main the belly so
originally Frank's Ennis who owned the
property came to my approach my father
write for the father for the Comedy
Store and said Sammy would you like to
open a room on Sunset and he said yes
and then they came up with a name the
calm is so original it was just the
original room and that was a guy named
Frank cenis and then the main room was
next door and that
yeah that would create connections
exactly knock the wall down they knocked
the wall down in between the two the
venue's and then from there what
happened was is she took over the main
room from art LeBeau and that was when
she opened it up and then that's when
she started thinking paying people you
don't even mean because there's a bigger
room and bigger names and that type of
stuff so yeah and then that was the
belly room as well yeah so do you know
the first lineup ever that well it was
probably like [ __ ] red fox or some
[ __ ] and then like he was a little bit
later when the early years like natural
gas did you ever hear natural gas I've
heard of natural gas yeah yeah he was
that was like Vic Dunlop and Dave Tyree
and some other guy and then I think
Danny John Denny Johnson was there at
Gallagher was there Jimmy Walker was
there Jimmy Walker was [ __ ] huge yeah
huge like big like that sitcom I mean to
this day it's just still really funny no
I should excuse me
reruns of that show so yeah so yeah that
was kind of like the first the first
lineups yeah your mother didn't let you
perform the Comedy Store - you got funny
huh that's how I got famous I started
you know but guess what I everybody
things they do that you had to earn it
no I get to go to the other claw that do
rooms right yeah I did I did that
purposely though I did that my choice
cabaret yeah and it still feels that way
you know it still feels like a Mitzi Sun
at the Comedy Store and it'll never go
away you know it's just like a weird
[ __ ] thing I'm actually more
uncomfortable at the Comedy Store than I
am like at the funny bone in Cincinnati
you only mean because it's like it's
just because my mom's there just because
she's physically not there she's still
there oh yeah I mean you can feel it
right yeah what you doing don't [ __ ]
with that
you're ruined it
leave it alone it's fine they [ __ ] up
the bathrooms they do with the bathrooms
the new bathrooms running yeah they're
[ __ ] they should be black with yes
yeah I remember with the red lifting
yeah but yeah no I worked the Laugh
Factory I went to New York that's where
I met Chris Rock
I saw Sandler out there and then and I
finally showcase for it didn't go well
when I showcase for two years after I
started doing stand-up she was next to
Louie Anderson and Paul Mooney they were
there and I ended I end it with pop
walking and then I went to my mom I said
how was she stick with the dancing yeah
you know that's good because you went
out and struck out on your own then you
went out and did your own thing and then
of movies at camera yeah so until I
became known all over MTV announced ill
wasn't ready
that's why it's funny when like I mean
not to diss Adam egit or anything cuz
he's doing the best that he can he does
a great job but you know when people
comics say oh I got I got passed I'm
like whatever you got passed you do
great videos I know that Hartman now he
did like 40 with a whole year of
showcases yeah yeah pretty much makes it
made him stable home all week you can
all hear you can but the one thing she
did with Howie is that um is that you
know she encouraged him not to go back
to Canada cuz I think he's so carpets
yeah I think that's what it was and he
on a roll the end of the roll hello yeah
it's a carpet company in Canada they
booked more attend to do a show yeah
into the road I'm pretty sure he works
for into the Roy
for Canada Wow it's a huge Canadian
carpet yeah the UM well soak Danica
say hi Danica what's that food somewhere
else you know you seen ghosts at The
Comedy Store
no people would say that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] it's not hard I don't see it I
mean yeah boo boo boo I don't know maybe
uh there was a doorman a long time ago
named Harris Pete who had been their
memory Harris people you know he was
there two years yeah he was there before
he was there before chewy and he said he
saw a ghost and Blake Blake Clark who
was a comic at the store he said he saw
a ghost I never saw a ghost
I never saw a ghost but it feels weird
when nobody's in there you know like
when we took your son and daughter there
Philippe yeah and we walked in the main
room just and it was just dark and you
were showing them around and then we
went off to the office but it was weird
office rug yellow arms shirts for the
kids or something like that yeah she
told me Thea why are people so harsh to
him oh there's no I don't know debacle I
get the whole pile harsh mr. Nemec oh no
we are not harsh he just did his name
came up during the story again well that
just brought it up the whole thing that
happened like a door like 14 years ago
yeah yeah a long time ago no yeah before
podcasts I audition for your movie
podcast our poly is dead
audition for it yeah I know we had
auditions yeah move the fake auditioning
the comedy story oh yeah at the comedy
right yeah I think mother Martinez got
me the game oh yeah [ __ ] she passed away
oh yeah my luck she was so funny she was
dirty and funny
she was great my mom loved her she was
great when I did you for your mom the
first time knowing a lot of people
around her talking to her so you can't
really pay attention cuz no I hear
everything you know you're [ __ ]
talking about Peter Chan and Peter Chan
is hilarious shake them golden oh yeah
happy now yeah
so the second week I had our Cheryl
Shepard and very much in estate next to
your mom - comedian block talked to her
blog it was tight and then she passed
you right yeah
you know who I you know I got hooked up
with my mom at the store was Robyn
Harris remember Rob Harris Bebe's kids
he's funny so fun brother Harold bro
well you know bound up in case some
[ __ ] start some where's the flu
he was up but he was on Fat Tuesdays at
the next door yeah and I saw him I'm
like oh my god this guy's so funny I
brought him next door and I said mom
this guy's got to go on and he went on
and then he became a regular and then he
I guess he died was like a year later or
something died at 37 after that movie
was so funny
[ __ ] [ __ ] that one elbow he has the
hilarious dude baby baby kids there's
that one half-hour HBO special yeah
babies kids became the cartoon right
yeah he did house party earth for that
movie yeah house party and do the right
thing yeah do the right thing
slick what's up party sure what's that
food Chinese so so yes so we used to be
unsnapped together when my mom yeah my
mom was around and because when I took
care of my mom for cook yeah Alfred who
was the Filipino caregiver for my mom
he's really bugging this guy early in
his house early in the morning they got
everybody everybody watching me then
they were 13 Chinese soup all the time
ah yeah cuz you know keep [ __ ] youth
you just killed it yeah you make great
your mama'll too low bass yeah yeah it's
good it's good for my bones
badass car convertible oh yeah the green
car yeah the green car I have a 69
Roadrunner yeah I got that in 94 and I
got that I was like a present to myself
after I did in the army now and it was a
it's the Pomona it's car show out there
and there's all these cars and I went
there and I just give him $14,000 cash
this summer let's do it though I do we
get home see they've been married no
kids
mmm nobody's out there it's really hard
for me it's really hard for me do yours
Tori that's kind of an excuse people
just wanna be married and kids I mean
you know here's the issue from me like
right now is like you know I'm being 50
51 years old it's like yeah if we're
gonna do it we got it we got to make
this [ __ ] happen soon so I'm trying to
figure out a situation that works for
for me and a
male you know some more if it's it's
more I don't wanna say a business move
because that sounds [ __ ] disgusting
maybe a partner exactly where it's like
yo like here's my semen here's like rent
you know here's everything like I'm
gonna still do my thing but our
relationship me and the girl we don't
know where the [ __ ] that's gonna go yeah
because how long you guys been together
for 13 years yes so it developed into
this thing it's a natural thing you know
and you guys met what forty or forty you
were left 39:34 yes so you were yes so
you guys but you guys all were young and
you develop that's normal that's the
normal way you develop you start dating
and pop up that it up yes I never did
that so now cuz I'm older I can't think
like that because I don't know because I
don't know you've just always been fit
in whenever you've got a free moment
yeah it's also hard for me to trust
women every girl I've ever dated cheats
on me you know what I mean but no cheat
on them too you know yeah I was trying
to get him little baby homes
girl and if she hears that she'll deny
it which is fine no way that's like
[ __ ] dude that did happy do your
stupid let me tell my side the story
she said she's adorable I did this girl
for a while and you know I would go on
the road and like you know there's girls
out there that are kind of voluptuous
and like part of the show is to you know
to hook up yeah they you know what I
mean
they're like excited you know what I
mean there should be a show Harmon to be
marries women out there that say their
husbands said I can have sex with them
yeah when I was just what I've heard
that before yeah they're guys who
sometimes push their way on how to you
during the meet-and-greet
right yeah it's like no I don't need to
have sex with you so your husband can
jerk off in the corner you know or
whatever nobody puts Baby in a corner
yeah so so I was with this one girl and
and she I found out she was cheating on
me but she was like living with the dude
oh so really she was cheating on him
with me which is hilarious oh [ __ ] so
for a long I wouldn't say living with
them but staying with him yeah you know
you mean and and I get it whatever dude
like but that's my that's my fault you
and I mean that's my fault so I don't
blame her I blame me she was young she's
young yeah she's uh little she's 30 now
so she's she was like I started dating
her in her early 20s so that was a while
ago though like I don't know I'll figure
it out so you just want to have your
baby and then you're just like Brendan
see what happens to our relationship
because I don't know you no one knows
where that goes as long as you
understand that you guys can co-parent
yeah normally then the relationship will
maybe take care of us over not or not or
yes you know so that's a reality I don't
have a [ __ ] choice you know unless I
meet someone and I we
we have a kid at [ __ ] 60 that's too
crusty crusty bro I mean Jamie Masada
did it yeah well that's not cool
you'll feel bonds dad had a match 70
what yeah he did oh I think matters I
think Matt Walker's dad is real bleep
kill Vaughn's dad had him at 70 yeah
that was really make a roberson like
that yeah my gramma had a baby at 55
what Wow lots of the Mohican what the
[ __ ] the baby look let her know he's
giving me hope that she doctor tell me
that's medically impossible I'm on dude
I don't have another a on my dad's side
I had a baby everything whoa but I think
from me like you know since my parents
passed and and you know I've had a lot
of sadness my mother friend died on my
sister died like all this [ __ ] happened
like it's been this kind of black cloud
in my life
you know I mean there's been a sadness
and I will get through it you know I got
to keep moving forward my parents don't
want me to be sad they want me to you
know hey you know so I think that having
a child would bring this kind of joy in
my life because when I do see kids I
really enjoy kids it's not like I might
get that little [ __ ] out here at the
airport's I'm always doing shtick my
patient fun yeah yeah I have a niece and
a nephew okay yeah so but people are
stalking they know you live in Sarah
yeah Paulie been living at Silver Lake
talking seven years I like it out there
I still wanted to [ __ ] call me you
moved in when it was expensive seven
years ago
hell yeah I like there I ran I ran I
rent so it's like I ran on a like in the
four Plex yeah so it's cool I like it
it's there's something very relaxing
about that area like Echo Park and Los
Feliz and so
like and you know you can dress like
this you don't have like West Hollywood
in Beverly Hills it's a hole do you feel
that the feeling that you get when you
go to yeah the dogs get Botox over there
but uh yeah so it's it's pretty cool out
there yeah well I screwed you go - I
went to Beverly Hills High School yeah
yeah there were to him that - or nobody
yeah yeah but we didn't live in Beverly
Hills we lived outside of Beverly Hills
so we had like a someone take us to
school and the other thing yeah so
that's cool man you do good in Florida
huh Florida I like Florida I saw you at
at the radio station oh yeah you were
promoting their Rock Show The Rock Show
are they doing a rock show down there
well that's all
Oh like the 90s show there's only have
one HBO with the right with the carpool
one bothers no way your buddy was
catering oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I know
my friend Joey produced it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yes I was talking about the
move before the [ __ ] movie came out
which the way the show gman came out
here you were talking about yes yeah it
was just talking about ball yeah just go
it was just coming out so um yeah I like
I like the guys down there Paul right
Paul Young Ron Paul you're on yeah yeah
nice guys yeah do you like the road I do
yeah it's nice isn't it yeah we're very
fortunate yeah you know how do you feel
when you like come home after the road I
feel good you know what I mean hey I
just I made all these people laugh I
gave my soul to these people I got money
you know I mean I'll and me and my girl
you know I mean let's have a nice meal
yeah yeah I mean it's pretty cold you
get massages
hell yeah I don't want the other
pedicure today for the first time sick
oh yeah I got something today I got
today that are facial for the first time
they sucked up the [ __ ] love black
and white black here's out of my face
doing I'm doing appeal I'll hook you
know I'll hook you up with the place I'm
going to do they get rid of all my my
freckles and like this sunspot you can
get a peel you still look the same it's
not gonna look weird but they just it's
like it's like a scrub on your face it's
like a five day peel I'm gonna do it
like next month then you like have like
stuff hanging off your skin for a few
days today man the sauna yeah I go to a
Korean spy all the time which one
there's one on our tower yeah it's like
Olympic yeah big one no it's a small one
but I go with I mean I see Bobby Lee
there a lot so we go there and it's cool
there's uh I think it's important you
know the spa the song is you go in there
and you take the shower and from there
you go to the the hot pool and then you
go into the sauna and the steam and then
you go into the cold plunge and you sit
there and you watch [ __ ] you watch
basketball these Asian dudes in the
[ __ ] thing and and I'm looking at
them this hilarious the cold plunge
Coppola in a hot bath attack and it's
good for this it's good for this yeah
when I came out of that play today my
forehead felt tight yeah I think yeah
massages are important especially when
you're on tour and you're sitting on
planes I got my first pedicure but I
never had a pedicure of my life
they put like sugar on my feet the lower
your girl sugar scram the water had like
roses and and lemon I thought you were
making a michelada
[Laughter]
whatever you have you been all over the
world yeah
Prague all that [ __ ] I went to Saudi
Arabia to do shows yeah this last well
there's a body with their swords was
funny because I my act is pretty dirty
yeah I'm pretty dirty and I we have
restrictions of course which victim will
know when I went I was [ __ ] scared I
know there's a comedy club there called
Al comedy club and when I went there if
you heard of it no it's called Al comedy
club I'm like who the [ __ ] is al no they
said no the comedy club means out so I
went there and I told them the man the
owner his name was Yasir Yasir he goes
what are you gonna do I'm like why talk
about sex that I like you can't talk
about any of that [ __ ] I go I guess
we're doing a Q&A and I did a Q&A oh
really yeah turn around
Godfrey Godfrey went on Godfrey went on
before me he did really well Godfrey's a
strong comic he's mostly clean - yeah he
can work at [ __ ] I can't work in that
[ __ ] yeah too much I think
you can't drink none of that [ __ ] over
there do nothing like holding hands or
dating what because they know they're
just starting to take off their [ __ ] the
women are just starting to like take off
their burkas and stuff showing them
ankles I would have said don't you able
to go to date and her mom
[Laughter]
and then overseas where else that iconic
ah yeah I went Africa Australia it's
been a while but yeah how about
Amsterdam Rotterdam mmm I went there
when you started blowing up so what was
the first thing that got you out of the
gate like that got you noticed and on
2mt because I remember I was in college
when he was on MTV like all the time
yeah so what was the first thing was it
like a spring break you were hosting
because I kind of remember it was all
about all these movies just start coming
out so like what was the first thing out
of the gate that really got you noticed
was MTV show yeah that was the big one I
would've been commercial - no put it
back no no MTV MTV was so big back then
yeah yeah think we're all the eyeballs
were it was on inner kid in our quad
like it was Ron in the little main room
for everybody where everybody was yeah
it was such a great gig it was like I
was on for 5 years every day from 3:00
to 4:00 it still lasts here we are 30
years later it's still [ __ ] is strong
I've gone through airports be later
works for me it was a psyche
you know it's America's psyche there's
nothing like that anymore well part of
short - a photo with somebody at a show
last week and a person were wearing a
polyester shirt they don't even sell oh
really
a bootleg one but a good one mm-hmm I
wanted a bastard man oh yes yes right oh
yeah no it's cool
so you I love your merch was so much but
you PI didn't get a dime of it huh you
eat when you're younger I came to be
merged you do a lot of teacher with your
name on it there there is that way now -
I mean I'm sure if you Google you know
your name right now other ones people
make yeah they make it you know that's
just what are you gonna do oh I'm gonna
hire a lawyer to stop that it's like
[ __ ] now it's like whatever right is it
worth fighting that's not a question
[ __ ] it you know whatever people want
you might have lost 20 bucks on that
shirt or whatever you are Howard Stern a
couple of time your anyway the funniest
hmm thank you could you keep it real say
something about here we go even now
buddy I never been a child see they
don't want me
uh-huh oh yes that was cool Bernhard you
brought that [ __ ] up bro
yeah what's [ __ ] up she's like what
the book it's like what do you know did
I try to [ __ ] you or something I was
like I'm gonna come perfect for your
show
young man it's like she's just weird
people are weird there what is she no
mana
she wouldn't have me on every time I had
a movie coming out or a special or
something about it like in like my I
hire my rogers & Cowan publicists you
know I'm paying what five thousand a
month or whatever and and you know get
me on this show I'm fly to New York boom
I'm doing all my press she's always like
Spach she started I think I don't know
she came through and then she plucked a
lot of comics story you know like I
don't open her level really honestly I
think I don't know I think maybe because
I would call her out or something I
don't know because then she [ __ ] the
owner of a or some [ __ ] she was she was
[ __ ] there's nothing wrong with she
said look we'll put party on well she at
one point did say well you know I was
drunk all the time I didn't realize like
how annoying he was or how I really
didn't have feelings for this guy anyway
but she got a lot out of it worked for
her for a while yeah yeah when you when
McCallum Sen Joe Rogan went at it mmm
and yeah who called you told you or how
did you find out well because a video
yeah I think the video went it was more
like it was more like I was kind of like
for me it was like yeah I was just kind
of like I definitely obviously think
it's
terrible that comics steel material I
wasn't I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened but I just thought it was kind
of gnarly that they put it on the
Internet yeah okay most yeah it was like
I thought it was kind of gnarly that but
Joe you know Joe is very he felt very
strongly to out them you know which is
cool
you know I mean because maybe that
stopped other comics in the future like
hey I'm not gonna steal people's [ __ ]
because some because that at the end of
the day like our shit's not copyrighted
no no well if you record it it is but
not for doing yeah but it has to be yeah
it's there are ways to get around it but
like you couldn't yeah you could have
yeah you'd have to take somebody to
court with it but you can copyright like
an audio recording I recorded a better
yeah but but what are you gonna do
things like alright cool people like
don't steal Animorph say this some
people there's a lot of rewriters at the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] same primaries and show
like that come on man yeah I was gonna
start looking at his stuff and tweak it
as I think it's a feeling that you have
as a comic on stage if you're doing
other people's [ __ ] then that's a shitty
feeling so why would you want to create
that feeling for yourself you know cuz
comedies I know it's an authentic thing
and it's like there's no there's no
filters there you know it's you and the
audience and if you're up there doing
other people's [ __ ] that's pretty [ __ ]
up nice and relevancy all types of [ __ ]
well but your mom did she ban all of
them what did she do she ended up she
banjo for a while in the beginning they
both were banned I think there I'm not I
don't really remember I just remember
that she was mad came back and started
doing shows didn't like the main room by
the time men seals bigger than Rogan at
the time yeah yeah and that was why
Rogan called a mouse house that happened
there before that comedian fighting
before you knew Roy
when you were coming though usually
community at it yeah but with the meet
with it but because of stealing or going
over your time no no I think I think I
know a fight between they were Alan
Grier and that was over [ __ ] and
moaning over who these days I even even
know 300 repair D somebody else actually
angrier and polish or fighting know why
we fight him bro I don't understand what
these [ __ ] want to fight go
ahead and take him down with the one to
Louisiana punch I wrote for Pryor and I
wrote for you now get the [ __ ] home I
was funny I was very funny Lisa said on
the stage and just sit on the still in
talk [ __ ] nobody but I know that Sam
Kennison and Andrew Dice Clay went at it
yes yeah I know that that happened the
second but that was but that was that
was because I think dice blew up all
quick and huge kinda and then also like
yes Sam I don't I didn't think that Sam
really liked wasn't wasn't a fan of
dices stick oh yeah you know comedy or
yeah Sam also went after Bobcat
Goldthwait yeah went after I'm hard
because you know
and I don't know how that I don't know
how that coincides with Sam's comparing
apples to oranges let's go get SARS
right you know we're parichi I'm kind of
like I'm kind of like I'm kind of like
maybe surprised that there's not more
kind of you know this with comics
because there are with rappers yeah you
mean like you I'm surprised I'm
surprised more people don't call out
comedian when they bomb like when I was
coming up did you bother make it
supportive now Polly they walk up to him
like his mom died in a car accident a
bomb and I was gonna say hello to him
like we never met I probably wouldn't
say hello to him bro okay bomb nice
truck I know what he's feeling and know
what it feel like to bomb yeah but
there's people that that Bob and there's
two deaths in the death floor yeah after
trying your [ __ ] stone about the great
part about stand-up is if you have a
shitty set it's fine because guess what
the next night you're gonna go up and
not have a shitty set but if you're done
coming you don't know that man you do
the end of the world
yeah ya know what the hardest you bombed
and went wasn't who was there
oh man and did you get [ __ ] Yeah right
bomb and get [ __ ] oh that's a
superpower it there there was a time I
remember when I first started and Argus
got me a spot at was at the alley cat
Bistro in no not the alley it was the LA
Cabaret which was a comedy club in the
valley for that yeah it's a great room
right it's [ __ ] like ya know when
there's like 300 400 seats it's like
really yeah I was dope back in the day
boy with Toro
yeah and Argos got me the owner was
named Ray and I just this was it that
this was the pocket between when I first
started and before I showcase when my
mom was in that two-year kind of pocket
and I was working at the Laugh Factory
was working around town and Argus got me
a gig there
and it was a Saturday night and I just
[ __ ] bombed it was so bad in Rey
called Argus and [ __ ] yelled at him
but for Argus Argus cut got me on that
stage because of cocaine because there
was like a drug [ __ ] exchange oh my
god that's how he got me on stage he's
like y'all give you coke if you put poly
on something like that type [ __ ] like a
soldiers oh hey [ __ ] you whatever works
I know I had a weird set the cool won't
have been bathroom their owner
complained them no I just
I killed the room and then and then
anybody yo anything wedding and every
joke didn't work and I was nervous and
gonna mean and then I also I had a bad
set was that the Gotham it was probably
about seven years ago it's [ __ ] weird
you know I mean I wasn't it was kind of
like being at the store like they
weren't there to see me right and I just
kind of went up and it was like just
every stroke just started kicking me
down you finally I'm like just sweating
at the brown like alright goodnight the
gay guys like what the [ __ ] was that
[Laughter]
but but the thing is that's the way it
is like you and I have an audience yeah
they come to see us and I never bomb in
front of my audience I have cells that
are okay but I [ __ ] pretty much kill
I [ __ ] go up there and I'm you know
I'm getting paid to [ __ ] just bring
it bring it and I [ __ ] go up there
and I'd have fun and I enjoy it and
that's I don't want to say it's easier
but I don't really get nervous because
you know before I go in front of school
it's all good and there's love and it's
like aw like heartfelt then you go to
the store you go to Gotham you go to
these kind of the cellar yeah you know I
mean I've only been on the cellar once
they did it all right
but it's just it's kind of weird you
don't even mean you kiss right I know
that way through the way you're Spanish
so it's different for you because you're
so accepted yeah right yes go do the
show with my ABS and they're all urban
yeah I wanna I gotta earn that audience
yeah a scene yeah and what I'd like to
do is open for Chappelle have you opened
for him ever we should open for him
which Dave if you're out there put me
and Philippe on your [ __ ] show bro
yes get rid of those two people they've
been waiting for two years so when you
so have you had any have you had any
real friendships among comics or do you
feel like being who you are you know MIT
CSUN and all that stuff and you know not
really sure what your power is at the
store now that do you feel like you
don't get like true friendships with
comics either or do you have some yeah
really close I mean the comics are my
brothers
yeah I mean they're all my brothers you
know what I mean so I very very feel
very comfortable with all of them so
yeah yeah at least that's how I feel so
you know how many brother Reba did you
have when you were laying on MTV
you know one fares the Daisy Duke show
when that cute mother when I brush the
bottom did you when I graduated high
school I had his outfit on wearing a
pink tank top and I had those shorts
they were from oh they were can I get
some of the Opie and they were a
checkered board like the ones that
Donnie and then everywhere and I had a
high table Reeboks mmm the blue ones the
one that came out back in the day the
white ones uh-huh it had a [ __ ]
Heather with lime-green that was the
Wiis the [ __ ] scarf the [ __ ] um
the [ __ ] scars on my pants believably
scarfs what it was called the scars I
took those from my mom looking like a
hip liquor liquor Street genie even
Tyler she holdover from the 80s though
all that stuff came into the 90 what was
it like in Ohio back then Zappa Madonna
know when in that 90's when you were
popular like at the height of all that
stuff oh the rehab when it when he gave
me popular well when I went I was in
college but I was having culture shock
because I went to black schools and then
my college was mostly white so everybody
there it was vanilla ice I think Ice Ice
Baby had come out around that time and
man I don't know it was it was boring
Cyrus right Mikey breaking yeah I guess
that was because I worked at a golf
course and there were people doing work
Oh Madinah stuff you're telling the 2
Live Crew my life Monica - yeah my world
was pretty much like what the Obamas
world was back in the day that was a big
ol poor black poor white that was me
that was me ugly sweaters fool we're
gonna be in Dallas those are gonna came
to the show last week I said the ER we
heard hey he told Johnny hey Johnny I
heard you on Rodeo in Brazil podcast oh
yeah that's a guy easy pay my HBO go man
yeah would you a shot coming up yeah we
got a lacuna January 22nd and East LA at
the Paramount I gotta ask you a quick
question what's up with that bullet hold
Sam Kinison left on the in the back of
the parking lot of the comedy store they
took it down what happened to it why did
it take it in corporate [ __ ]
Yeah right no I didn't even know they
took it down a bullet it was as they
sign it right there where you walk to
the back the entrance they had that one
they said the comedy short it was a
bullet hole that Sam Kinison left and
then now it's gone I didn't know that I
thought it was still there I knew so
what they're dying to dying for me to
ask you Alex cotton yadah asked him
about when he was on a Joe Diaz podcast
nobody wants to know about the edibles
and all that did you do edibles yeah I
do edibles now but you know what the
drugs right cocaine a little bit once in
a while you know look Argus Hamilton I
don't like cocaine I just like the way
it smells but no I what happened was
with Joe he asked me to be on the
podcast and I went in and he gave me
these gummies and I never really done
gummies and I didn't know what what
level they started to death yeah choose
I don't know what it was it was like
just an it was some of it so I took it I
took it and then halfway through our
podcast I couldn't speak so then I had
to leave I didn't leave I left I said
dude I gotta get it yeah he [ __ ] let
me drive sure yeah you naughty get up
this be my edibles you don't know which
part has the most weed you know yeah
yeah but what happen used to ride in
those motherhood when I was driving when
I was driving home from his podcast I
was literally like yeah but now I take
them once in a while and I have the
perfect amount so I'm good I like
edibles
they're great Barwis
I think it makes pretty Marley no none
of it does anything for you what's your
thing what's your vice yes bro yo talk
show or like a Comedy Central or Cartoon
Network questions like people ask you
questions
[Laughter]
are there any bad rumors I got you or
any rumors that people spread ever
spread about you over the years in a row
bro you died I don't know what I don't
know I don't know nothing you know did
you see your brother's idea for that
judge movie jury duty jury duty somebody
else's they saw my idea what idea well
tell you say it on stage you were buzzed
and that's why I perform okay and you
say you and your brother your brother
were fighting over jury duty
oh no that's I don't how Justin had live
where'd you get that Richard Pryor sure
duck the dudes Rosen yeah you know him
right yeah that makes the pins no the
guy that the guy that makes the all
rockin pins yeah that make really so
Peter you ever seen it yeah so he made
yeah he's a cool kid I went to kill Tony
Monday and he came backstage he was
really nice he said hey you can have
this and he started the new Richard
Pryor the new Richard Pryor Instagram
with Jennifer Pryor oh he started yeah
he's a nice kid so uh that actually that
special is coming out I think ten
tomorrow night or something in the
Richard Pryor 20/20 oh it's on 20/20
they interviewed a whole bunch of people
and they uh yeah cuz you know somebody
said there's a rumors of your death did
you have rumors that you don't know
there's a movie or that you almost sold
the comedy store mmm no no right how's
the movie polishers dead I like that of
the video they were growing you about
your dad after sweet much fun there goes
my hero
oh when your nose my eyes crazy
good relationship like like people
people who don't have a good relation to
the dead like my side would have let you
know wow that's uh that's all due to
strive must be nice
well my dad my dad and I tour with him
your dad or your dad an interview I
thought he was so sweet said I was a
real weasel yeah
the original weasel he was yeah yeah he
started it off there wasn't my dad there
would have been no Comedy Store yeah
he's the one that started crazy he's the
one that started it came in with
nobody's getting [ __ ] up all week yeah
Rudy DeLuca they started and they
started it and then their divorce
instead he would work in Vegas right
open him for Sinatra and all those dudes
or yeah my dad my dad opened for uh you
know Tony Bennett a lot Engelbert
Humperdinck you know Don Rickles and
then you know Elvis Presley yeah for
many years
yeah my dad was you know he started
doing stand-up in the 1950s
I'm sure yeah so he was you know he was
on Sanford and Son Sanford and Son and
and he did a movie with Jerry Lewis
called the bellboy he twos my dad was
like by the way man
yeah he started it he did Ed Sullivan he
was very good you know where'd he meet
your mom
Elkhart Lake Wisconsin Wow yeah your
mother - Oh what happened was is my dad
was performing at the camp in Elkhart
Lake Wisconsin like doing his shtick and
then she worked for the boss further at
the camp so she started watching my
dad's act and she would type up jokes
for him he's already working yeah she
gave him pointers no just pointers
direction do this don't do that and bad
sex he took off and then she called him
and said I'm pregnant
and Ivanhoe my oldest brother Scott is
gonna be 70 in like three four years
yeah you're late baby you were the baby
I was the baby yeah wow that's crazy
stuff yeah don't you sing a mariachi
band in here right now you should get a
mariachi band back here be hilarious
thanks coming up people this weekend
Dallas Texas area
Addison improv as a nipple with um hey
with a guy named Keith Manning you know
plea cuz note that is an improv the old
man just next week 20 seconds Keith why
not Mexico all shows Spanish all Spanish
oh that's [ __ ] that's the real Santa
Cruz January 25th almost sold out at the
catalyst one night only Pasadena the 26
Ice House stage two but that's all
Spanish show you have two shows we added
a second show today for a second show
that night is the first one sold out so
two spanish shows that night and that is
the last practice before you film your
specials for netflix on the 27th and
28th in santa ana there too I think the
English shows are all sought out for
that 2007 and 10 6 p.m. doors 9 p.m.
doors in a minute my letter throw my
stuff
go ahead but okay Casey improv this
weekend and then after that I'm going to
Miami for the Superbowl
I'm the Super Bowl halftime show shot
out of a cannon and I don't know just go
to Pauly Shore calm or follow me on my
Instagram which is that Pauly Shore and
you'll see my tour bass also my podcast
which I know you coming up called random
rants
I'm doing it today with Tony Hinchcliffe
he's coming over to the house and then
people said they love random rants yeah
it's fun I really enjoy it i real
enjoy it yeah it's a it's a fun it's
different are you doing a one-man show
now to you about what your act is now or
you're doing two separate things I do
the stand-up and I also do a one-man
show the one-man show what's the story
behind yeah the stories in my child okay
yeah we were that I'm putting it
together right now so eventually
hopefully Netflix or something like that
would be did you tour with it already
yeah yeah I've been working it for a
while so my managers are talking about
putting it at just for laughs
hopefully this July or Melbourne I think
that's in March though and it might be
too late
so yeah I'm working it and I also have a
big piece in The New York Times coming
out on Sunday Arts and Leisure section
they did a big spread opening up in
other parts of the country just they
will write right now have no idea
are you involved in operations or
anything your silent owner portion and
all that stuff
oh I'm one of the owners I don't know
it's kind of like a weird thing right
now so I'm dealing with that [ __ ] right
now yeah no I don't like how I've missed
something you see like it let homeless
people in yeah I was doing I was doing
kill Tony and there's these the you know
the comics they come on stage they're
pretty much homeless guys yeah I told
the one guy I'm like dude you should
sleep backstage cuz I used to like
comics sleep backstage dombarris you
know yeah he [ __ ] he's asleep
backstage Todd like trust Fleischer
didn't he do a lot of the construction
inside my mom's carpenter yeah like I
won in the morning or in the backpack
and then because I was so lonely you
know but now you can't do it anymore
me too I would do a show like as a
mother to that far and then after that
show in at 10:00
I would bring like whoever where to come
and get [ __ ] up and dub me see those
who she bore me I guess let's go over
here and get some sushi cos it's cheap
right now and then we'll catch this
crazy show with Dom Barrett color
ding-dongs yeah first things you try to
take me
only like Mexicans here yeah and
everyone watching this crazy show is a
freak show actually and then that guy
ends up being the warm-up guy for a
Kimmel right yeah and one of the guys
was caught by a memo wanted for being a
child molester
oh [ __ ] for Aladeen don't show comics
what Chinese babies Chinese babies just
appalling short for Las Vegas Comedy
Central special with what's-her-name no
good The West Wing card suit oh that's
nothing especially you do it like this
like oh that was great don't know that
sure oh you had a suit on oh yeah bro
shrim Harrison do it first show I think
you were doing with that with him Buddy
Holly not even like it wasn't like
exactly where the suit but he do like um
more personal but Joe's were not about
being goofy ladies regular act it was
straight up stand up and he talked the
more about army family yeah that was
cool I was at Eliza Steve Steve
Rannazzisi one of those I don't know I
mean I'm doing you know I got the
podcasts of doing I'm doing the one-man
show and a movie just came out at
Lionsgate called a big trip which is an
animation and I have guest house coming
out this year everybody said that goofy
movie they loved you oh yeah bro do a
peanut call what's up
yeah man podcast and also check out our
new Spanish podcast six episodes
those podcasters up north day with my
homeboy right here mark where do the
podcast air wouldn't they come out every
week on you know YouTube and Spotify and
all that stuff so you know cool man
think about being here man
congratulations
congratulations on your stuff I know
you've been working in art so oh yeah
thank you I'm glad that she's your wife
indianature yes keep it in the family